this is the iphone 12 and this is the
iphone 12 pro
and you may have heard they have a
little thing called 5g 5g
5d5
and apparently with these new phones 5g
just got real
sure 5g on your new iphone is real
if you were actually allowed into places
like this right now
the fastest of fast 5g service is really
only
in big public spots like the three
billion dollar metlife stadium
this whole space is equipped with
verizon ultra wide band 5g antennas and
radios
my boss has said work from anywhere so i
work here now just me
my iphones and some super fast verizon
5g
certainly 5g is the most hyped feature
of these new phones
but i've been testing them and it's not
the game-winning feature
if you're upgrading it's all about the
cameras and the design but given that
these look
so similar and have the same 6.1 inch
screen
yet have a 200 price difference which
team do you pick
that's why these two have taken the
field
first quarter hardware design
[Music]
look this is the best iphone design in
years
even if it does look seven years old
almost exactly like the iphone 5.
the edges are nice and square the phone
lays almost flat on a table
and yes it's super thin and light it's
just so nice to hold
what are the design differences well the
iphone 12 has aluminum edges
the iphone 12 pro has stainless steel
edges which make it feel a little bit
more weighty
but it also makes it a fingerprint
magnet
speaking of magnets there's a circular
magnet in the back side of the phone
even lightweight fridge magnets stick to
it it's called magsafe
and apple has made accessories to clip
to the back of your phone
it's such a great idea in theory
this little wallet accessory is perfect
other than the fact that
this sometimes happens then there's the
39 dollar magsafe wireless charger
it charged the iphone 12 halfway faster
than a regular wireless charger
but not as fast as plugging right into a
20 watt charger
plus the magsafe cord isn't even a yard
and you need to buy a 20
charging brick since that's no longer
included in the box
oh both also have a new ceramic shield
glass which provides four times improved
drop performance
apple which lent me this phone to review
told me not to drop test it
second quarter cameras
both the 12 and the 12 pro have ultra
wide cameras
great for shots like this both
also have new regular wide cameras which
let in
27 percent more light according to apple
in my tests i could see a pretty
substantial improvement over the camera
on the iphone 11
and certainly over the old iphone 10.
the big difference is that the 12 pro
has a telephoto camera and honestly
whenever i switched back to the regular
iphone 12
i missed having it the pro also has a
lidar sensor which captures more depth
information about the scene
that enables night portrait mode on the
pro when it comes to video
both phones support dolby hdr video
recording
[Music]
yep it's on cameras that the iphone 12
pro scores the touchdown
third quarter 5g new 5g antennas and
radios are packed in this thing
which means your phone is capable of
really fast download speeds over a new
5g cellular network the issue again is
where is that network i mean clearly
it's here and that's why i'm here
now 5g is pretty complicated in the us
there are two types of 5g
here in this stadium there is the first
type called millimeter wave
this is super duper fast 5g but it's
only really available outdoors in big
metro areas
or in big gathering spots like this
verizon's ultra wideband network is
available in this stadium
but the other carriers have this fast
type of 5g too
just look at these speeds but to get
them i had to be in line of sight of the
5g antennas verizon's installed in here
[Music]
plus no one else is in here right now
still
that's 20 times faster than my home
wi-fi
and to the iphone's credit the oneplus 8
5g
also for verizon didn't notch those
speeds in my side-by-side tests
and even as i sit here with these
blazing fast 5g speeds what am i
supposed to do with them
download two seasons of breaking bad
already did that in three and a half
minutes
download a 2 gigabyte game done in 45
seconds
one good use hooking up your laptop to
the connection via a personal hotspot
apple says it's sped up the connection
between the phone and the laptop by
four times 5g also allows for facetime
hd
i would say the end zones are lightly
used the real use will be when this
place is filled with fans again and
everyone's trying to upload their photos
to instagram and videos to youtube
that sort of crazy fast 5g isn't likely
what you'll experience
most days the second type of 5g called
sub
6 isn't as fast but it covers longer
distances
and has outdoor and indoor coverage
fourth quarter everything else overall
battery was solid
at least on days when i wasn't in my
stadium office verizon's 5g
ultra wideband killed the battery
luckily i had my own personal charging
station
i did have the 5g on setting enabled all
day
but by default the iphone 12 has a smart
data mode
which only uses 5g when you need it like
downloading big files
both phones have an a14 processor and
they are very fast
but the iphone 12 pro starts with 128
gigabytes of storage space
while the 12 starts with 64 gigabytes
so who wins well the pro but only by a
field goal or two
still both of these phones are great
upgrades but remember
don't do it alone for that 5g very few
who will get this new iphone will see
speeds like this
in or near their homes but one day when
you can leave the house again
a world of fast speeds may await you
[Music]
you